wer bei shampoo
jede seite
er weiß schon heute wohlgemuth sind
immer wieder dass neu beginnt
o
ja wir sind in köln neben uns ist der
karneval zu 573 wir sind viele schöne
leute die verkleidet sind genau richtig
manny sacha und das ist uns gut gehen ja
hier sagt man karneval wirklich
verschicken und man sagt härle und nicht
hallo
ja
wir haben einen großen gefallen da
kommen sie vorbei
müsste eigentlich arbeiten oder so ist
sowieso eines meiner freizeit dann
gehört dazu
wer heute arbeite hat irgendwas am red
ja wir sind hier in köln keine ahnung wo
wir sind aber irgendwo eine schlange
wir wollen ein viertes rennen
berlin wir fragen was das schönste wort
in köln ist dass man sagen kann so jetzt
zu dieser zeit gibt kein wahlkampf
ausdrücklich einwilligt kann dadurch
freunde des bieres kombüse von bruder
gefüllt und wird jetzt also die ganze
zeit durch köln gelernt und uns keine
schmackhaft machen zu lassen gehen wir
jetzt nochmal wir extra seinen flinken 2
bis 18
alles was wir machen schluss für heute
in köln
wenn ich nur in eine kneipe schauen wo
uns der abend heute noch hin trägt auf
wiedersehen bis bald